is boxing for you really about revenge
no um it's just that you know i
i never um take my losses personal
you know and that's very difficult for
um athletes of any
any field to do i've learned that from
cuss that's why he's been such a great
mentor to me
you know how um
it's just not to be taken personal
because it would drive you nuts
and i just knew that um this is why um
in all disrespects and i'm not trying to
be um
vagaboses or sure but this is why i'm
successful now after boxing because i
didn't take it personal
i'm not trying to even the score
evander's still fighting he's still
trying to even the score
i'm not trying to even the score i'm
moving on
to other places which are probably dark
and um
places i've never been before but i'm
not afraid to go there i'm not afraid um
i'm not afraid to um lose in life
i'm not afraid to do anything i won't do
anything matter of fact i won't do
anything matter of fact like my show
there's nothing i would do unless i have
a possibility of being humiliated
if i can't be humiliated if i fail i
don't want to do it
because only by doing that i would rise
to my highest potential
without with the fact that i might be
humiliated and i don't want that to
happen
but when it does happen then um i will
truly be humiliated
because when i succeed i truly succeed
and that's why i'm here with you